foreign
this morning the rise of sumo wrestling
in America this ancient Japanese sport
is often misunderstood in the west and
for a long time was strongly discouraged
but a vocal group of sumo wrestlers in
California are doing their best to make
it mainstream that includes the
Relentless promoter of USA Sumo and a
former Sumo world champion
each at more than 600 pounds ryuchi
Yamamoto is the heaviest
japanese-born sumo wrestler in history
but he says don't be fooled by his
physique or the typical Sumo stereotypes
what do you think most Americans get
wrong about Sumo
[Laughter]
so Americans seem to have an image that
is just two really fat guys who stand in
the ring and just kind of hug each other
actually
so intense even in a second there are so
many different adjustments and things
and movements feeling your opponent
adjusting your techniques Sumo can be
traced back to the 8th century
full contact wrestling using a
combination of brains Brawn and even
some Judah
matches are often over in moments
as a professional Yama was a two-time
world champion who was rarely knocked
down
until he was knocked out
after being accused of fixing matches a
decade ago he was forced to retire from
Japanese sumo
he's attempting to reinvent himself in
America
predominantly getting paid to act as a
sumo wrestler
including in John Wick chapter two
Yama also helps instruct at the Yamamoto
Sumo dojo in Torrance California
alongside the director of USA Sumo
Andrew freund
you don't look like a sumo wrestler
I'm sorry
freund has spent the last 25 years
trying to broaden the appeal of Sumo in
the U.S by competing in and organizing
tournaments including the world's
largest outside Japan
[Applause]
because as beloved as Sumo is in the
east
freund says that Obsession became a
casualty of assimilation in the west I
think a lot of Japanese who immigrated
to the United States over the past
Century didn't continue the Sumo
tradition too much because there was a
little bit of a push to become
Americanized and because probably
mainstream American culture stigmatized
Sumo a little bit because they were just
treated as big fat guys they're a joke
which is a completely erroneous
stereotype
they're not guys that are just sitting
on a couch all day eating chips they
wake up at 5am they train all morning
for about five hours in a row literally
five hours of working out with no break
no food no water
yama's morning routine can cost him 10
to 15 pounds of sweat
which he replenishes with a protein and
nutrient-dense Sumo stew called Chango
nabe part of his 10 000 calorie per day
diet
but every wrestler is different
the interesting thing for for most
people to to learn actually for most
Americans to understand is that
traditionally in Japan in Sumo you
didn't have to be enormous
I see two of you I can't do that so
let's watch it first
regardless of size the stretching
routines are intense and give you an
appreciation for the athleticism
involved I am pushing you push
and then when yama's ready he's going to
go all the way down no he's not yes oh
yeah here we go
she can literally go to sleep if you're
willing to do the work
freund says it doesn't matter who you
are and then the referee will say come
away
please nor how you look doing it
he's hard to move man
let's bring the eight quarter finalists
as freund continues working to grow
sumo's presence in the U.S he says he'd
love to see it become an official
Olympic sports
something he feels is not Out Of Reach
we have people from almost every
background every ethnicity men and women
we have kids who've been practicing from
age six or seven with us we've had guys
come in here and they're like me in
their 50s or even older than that so
we've had the the full gamut of of
Americana basically do Sumo men and
women are part of sumo today yes and in
fact the U.S Zoom opened since 2001 we
have had not only the weight divisions
for men but the weight divisions for
women and that's kind of a requirement
to potentially get Sumo into the
Olympics
hmm the 23rd annual U.S Sumo open is
happening today really in Long Beach
California if you're in the area
interesting to note the top four
countries right now Russia Japan Ukraine
and Mongolia in sumo wrestling get about
80 percent of the medals in competition
the U.S only has about four or five of
the last 1 000 given out and only one
gold so they're hoping to change that
well you know you need to join the team
you're getting a little competitive
there it was the first time I did it a
little red in the face there Jeffrey I
almost knocked he almost went out of the
ring when I pushed it yeah that looked
on your face was like this is gonna
happen